Okay.
So now tell me how many,
how many members,
you don't have to discuss any of this
obviously,
but how many members of Heterodox
Academy are there now?
We have 1300 members.
So once we opened up,
it's originally was just where we
searchers who were studying this
problem,
but we had lots of people wanting to
join.
And so we said,
well,
okay,
why not?
And so we just said,
all right,
if as long as you're a professor,
um,
that is,
you have a phd,
you're living more or less the life of a
professor,
you have a university affiliation.
So we now take adjuncts if they have a
phd,
uh,
we take postdocs basically if you're in
the guild,
if you're living the life of a professor
and you're concerned about the rise of
intimidation,
frankly,
if you're concerned that our wonderful
institution I love,
I love being a professor.
I Love Adam and I feel like it's not
just losing public respect,
it's losing its ability to,
to function.
It's losing its ability to teach and do
research on politicized topics.
So there were more politicized topics
all the time.
That's,
that's right.
And there are few in the natural
sciences,
not many,
but there are some of the natural
sciences as well.
Anyway,
my point is we're now growing very
rapidly and something I'm very excited
by is since we've started having more
violence on campus with beginning with
birth and Middlebury,
we're seeing a pervasive sense among
people on the left that there really is
this problem here that something has to
be done.
And so we are finding much more
acceptance now,
um,
from professors on the left.
So I like to think about there's the
liberal left,
which is the great majority,
and there's the illiberal left.
We did a factor analysis of politically
correct beliefs and found exactly that
and that the,
and that the illiberal left was also
high in orderliness.
That's interesting.
That's the authoritarian.
Exactly.
Predisposition.
Yeah.
And also kind of markedly declined.
It was also characterized by a market,
lack of verbal intelligence.
Oh,
that's
0.4.
Well that,
oh,
that's beautiful.
That's beautiful.
Because one of the simplest formulations
I've heard really great formulation from
Mark Lilla.
So Mark Lilla wrote this fantastic op
ed.
The New York Times week after Trump was
elected saying identity politics is a
really foolish thing to do.
It pushes lots of people over to Trump's
side.
The identity politics as part of the
problem.
Well,
he writes this hotbed and one of his
fellow professors at Columbia,
I forget how she does it,
but she basically says something about
the,
you know,
the mask with eye holes falls from his
face.
Like,
you know,
he's a Ku Klux Klan members,
something like that.
And so Lilla Lilla who isn't humanities,
he's an intellectual historian.
Lilla has this simple formulation.
He says that's a slur,
not an argument.
And once they had that simple
formulation,
I realized,
wow,
that's almost all the push back I've
ever gotten.
It's somehow,
you know,
oh,
you're winking at Nazis or your comfort
to me over and over.
I was just,
my neighborhood was just posters with
all that intimidation.
So,
so this is really key.
We're supposed to be all about,
you can say anything you want,
you can make any argument you want.
If you can support it,
if you can back it with reasons.
This is critical thinking and this is
what we're supposed to train our
students to do.
Well.
And not only that,
you can say anything,
but you can say it.
There's a boundary on that,
which,
especially if you're a scientist,
less so in the humanities.
But if you're a scientist,
the things you say have to be vetted by
people who are going to be critical of
them.
Right.
So,
so not only do,
not only [inaudible] there's
accountability built into it.
That's right.
So I didn't mean to say you can say
whatever you want,
this brand.
I mean you can put forth any idea you
want,
if you can back it up.
What we're seeing with anything
politicize is it's not about backing it
up.
Students are learning rhetorical
techniques to link their enemies to
something racist.
Contemptible some tangible that's bad.
Those are the things that are not only
worthy of being destroyed,
but that you have a moral duty to
destroy.
Exactly.
So that's right.
So it's almost like the immune system,
how exactly it works.
But there's some cell that tags Acel as
you know,
enemy,
enemy.
And once that tad was put on the cell
that attracts other,
I forget what kind of cell to
[inaudible].
And so we should look into this,
this metaphor of the immune system,
because you know,
once they know,
once you're labeled as a racist,
students don't have to read you that.
It doesn't matter what you actually say.
You will now be a tap.
It's also too that once you're labeled
that way,
if someone defends you,
the label is contagious.
And it's our dynamic.
That's how we know where in this super
religious territory of witch hunts that
if you stand up for someone,
you are tagged and then you will be
mobbed.
Right?
And that's why there's so much disease
that,
and that's why there's so much cowardice
on campus among both students and
faculty.
People are afraid to stand up,
even if the majority think that what's
going on is nuts or is unfair.
They're afraid to stand up.
And that's in part due to social media
because it's just,
I mean,
students today had been raised with
various platforms that make it easy for
people to join in attack someone they
look at who liked what.
So if in that article we just saw on
read,
uh,
there was a bit of a counterrevolution
and read the students had to get
together somehow and decide should I
like that post?
How about if we all liked it at the same
time,
then we'll get in less trouble.
Okay.
So to what degree,
so let's talk about the aims of the
Heterodox Academy.
So you've brought people together who
are in principle interested in a
diversity of opinions and,
but,
but in what manner is that going to be
utilized to,
to,
I don't want to use the word combat,
but to,
but to deal with this emergent problem
of ideological rigidity in the
university.
So,
uh,
two useful concepts here.
One is the emperor's new clothes.
Um,
we all know that story.
even if most people,
even if everybody sees this is nuts,
the empress walking around with no
clothes,
they're afraid to say it until one
person says it.
So,
and this is also the ash experiment.
Everybody says that that line is the
same as that line is obviously not true.
If one person says the truth,
then nobody conforms after that.
So the mere presence of a group of
people who say,
you know what,
we actually need a diversity of
opinions.
And the fact that on our site we'll
publish things.
So sometimes when professors are mob,
like when Bret Weinstein,
you know,
was mobbed,
so I wrote an essay that stood up for
him.
Uh,
we've done that for some of them.
It's happening so fast.
I can't keep up.
I can't,
I've got books to write and I,
you know,
every week there's some new member was
getting mobbed.
And so we're going to develop a team of
people who will write.
But just knowing that there are people
who will stand up for you,
um,
knowing that there are people who will
say,
wait a second,
this is not what we do in the academy.
So that's one thing is we just stand up
for each other too,
is we develop products that we think can
basically fix the situation.
So one of our products is called the
campus expression survey.
It's a survey designed to actually
measure who was afraid of speaking up
about what topics and why,
what are they afraid of?
And it turns out everyone's afraid of
the students more than the faculty.
Uh,
they're afraid of mostly to talk about
race.
What about the administrators?
Everyone's afraid of the students.
They're afraid of the students.
So I don't have,
we've not sorted them.
I've only surveyed students.
Okay.
But from what we hear,
um,
uh,
people are afraid of,
of the students,
um,
you know,
well,
that's what your hauling,
hauling in its own manner.
Like was that real of leaders?
That's for sure.
They let those kids come into the
classroom,
the actual classroom and disrupt a class
on an ongoing basis.
I mean,
yes and I couldn't understand that
exactly.
I mean,
my response to that would be first I
would tell them to leave.
Second,
I would call campus security.
Third,
if something wasn't done about it,
I just wouldn't teach the class.
So I don't understand like it,
it seems to me that it's also up to
individual professors to draw a line,
which is that if you're being
intimidated,
dated by students,
why do you,
why do you show up and teach the class?
I don't understand that.
Yeah.
So again,
people are afraid to stand up if it
means that people will call you a
racist,
Cabot God.
I mean it's,
it's weird and that situation though,
because it's carried to third to go to
your class,
you know,
and there's a much more proximal thread
there.
That's what I mean.
What I'm most alarmed by is the rise of
intimidation.
Intimidation is now a factor in many
aspects of academic life.
And that's just terrible.
That's completely incompatible with,
with what we do and who we are.
Well,
it's especially,
it's especially appalling given that
whatever happens in the university
campuses,
you know,
like one of the questions I've faced in
Canada as well,
why should we care about what's
happening in the,
in the Ivy Tower is going to hire these
people next year.
You are?
Yeah.
Well it's the heart.
Like what's happening in the campuses is
going to happen in society in five
years.
It's already hot goats.
It's already happening.
So this is actually an important,
um,
I,
I just gave a talk at a,
at a big law firm here in New York where
they're very devoted to diversity,
but they're doing it right.
They're really about diversity.
Why is diversity good?
And so they have a whole month on
viewpoint diversity,
which is just fantastic.
And what I'm learning from talking to a
number of people in the business world
is that in the last year,
they're now all these pressures on
leaders to endorse this condemned that
signed this open letter and coming into
human resources.
That's right.
But it's the same dynamic we have on
campus and the answer to it.
So if anybody,
anybody watching here,
if you run a business,
if you have friends who are in business,
I think the only,
the,
they're only two stable equilibria.
One is that every organization is just
either,
all right wing were all left wing,
but that would be disastrous.
So you,
so are there,
you just say,
okay,
we're on one side,
that'd be terrible.
The other is what we call the Chicago
principles of free expression.
The University of Chicago has the best
statement out there on how the
university provides a platform on which
multiple views can contest.
The university does not take anyone's
side.
That's the only other stable
alternative.
And I think leaders need to do this in
business.
It certainly universities.
So we're encouraging every university to
adopt the Chicago principles because a
lot of what mass action is,
is an attempt to compel the authority to
come in on your side and punish your
enemies.
Yup.